huit ans
c'est quoi ça ça vient de là
au
bout
moi
depuis le jour où mon père n'a adopté
je me suis entraîné pour devenir un
grand aventurier comme j
premier candidat aux portugais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hopper chicken sonne c'est quoi ce nom
au fait moi ces mecs
pourquoi pas comme tout le monde
des choses qui nous rendent différents
sont celles qui n'ont rien
d'exceptionnel
parti tu sais que j'ai toujours rêvé d'
aventure nous allons découvrir le plus
fabuleux trésor de tous les fruits c'est
le cas de celui qui veut accéder au
temple du hamster des ténèbres
devra triompher de trois épreuves
mortelles
pourquoi toujours 3 pourquoi c'est
jamais deux épreuves mortelles
[Musique]
c'est parti
ouais
oh non
woerth chante un tu pousses comme
personne
la vente urgent never do